hey guys Pete here today I'm going to
make a video about some of the
interesting things that either I missed
or I failed to mention in my 20 season 3
episode 5 recap and review it does
contain spoilers for everything up until
that episode part 5 so if you haven't
watched that for yet you'll want to stop
watching now ok so the first thing that
is probably the most reported and
something I missed completely whenever I
watched the episode was that this guy
Richard who's the bad boy in the road
house smoking at the non-smoking table
is credited as Richard horn in the
credits now I think what's most
significant about this as far as what we
actually know is that this is a show
that has played around with the credits
in the past so the fact that they put it
there is sort of a clue as to who this
guy is now what that means is definitely
open to interpretation as there are
several horns who he could be related to
directly as in there his parents first
two that are the most obvious but not
necessarily the correct choices are Ben
and Jerry thorne
there may also their children would have
the horn last name in most cases and
unless it was like Ben fathering Donna
Hayward it could be either of these guys
then sleeps with just about everybody in
the original run and makes no bones
about it so he can certainly have popped
out another kid Jerry is not known to be
with anyone or was never really you know
had a female character in his story line
so that's a possibility as well and then
we also have John Johnny who is Audrey's
brother who you know was working with
dr. Jacoby in the original series he was
kind of insane or the Indian headdress
and whatnot but we know that he's not
coming back or at least the actor who
played him isn't so that makes him a
little less likely to be the father but
really don't know I mean the kid seems
to have some problems so he could be
related to that it could be related to
that as father it was kind of a nut job
and then there's Audrey Audrey could
have had a child and this brings up the
most theories and not all of them are
pleasant honestly I guess the big strike
against this theory is that his last
name is Horne
so that would mean that Audrey wasn't
married now some people had this idea
that maybe she had a child with agent
Cooper before he left town which would
have been you know evil coupe that we
know now and that's definitely possible
but there's a couple things that work
against it
we know that agent Cooper didn't stay in
Twin Peaks that long we don't know for
sure how long but basically after we saw
him come back and be inhabited by Bob he
didn't really do a lot the other thing
is is that audrey was in a major
explosion in that same time right so she
was in the hospital and honestly one of
the biggest things about her was people
thought she might still be in a coma 25
years later so we really don't we know
she's alive we know she lived through
the blast we don't know about her state
other than it was really bad whenever
that happened so I was reading something
today and you know the guy said well
maybe evil coop went and impregnated her
in the hospital while she was in the
coma which is kind of creepy but it's
also not beyond the scope so yeah
Richard Horne will find out more about
him in the upcoming episodes the next
thing was the music you might have
noticed that the music was missing when
he heard it in a couple select scenes
this time around and I'm not going to go
into all of that but it's something that
I read article about in relation to
season 4 because we all notice that
whenever Laura's being played when
Bobbie was crying after seeing the
picture music was the big part of the
original run and it's very sparse now so
the author of that article said maybe
the the fact that it's creeping back in
is a sign that things are going back
towards where they used to be so it's
just something to keep in mind next
episode when it comes out listen to when
the music comes up and tell me what you
think next we have these balloons
there's red balloons that we see when
dougie coupe is going in to work they're
on this little structure behind the
statue the law enforcement or cowboy
statue however you tend to look at it
when he goes in there's a lot of
balloons when he comes out there's only
one that might not be anything but it
was brought up that the drugged out
mother who's across the street from
Dougie's car has a balloon in her scenes
as well now she had it was originally
brought up in common
to me that maybe she had gone to sunny
Jim's birthday party which I didn't
think was likely since you know sunny
Jim and and the real dougie live in a
different neighborhood than where she's
located and she doesn't look like she
goes that far for home except maybe to
cop drugs but it came up again that this
balloon looks a lot like the balloons on
this structure and what that means I
don't really know but you guys tell me
what you think
to fit the fingerprints on the screen
when Tammy Preston is looking over the
case file for agent Cooper a lot of
people pulled this up and looked at it
closely more closely and it looks like
that the one that she has zoomed in on
here is a mirror image of the other on
you know the real Cooper's prints so
there's a lot of different things going
on in this image like the writing is
backwards on one but not the other so
I'm not going to get into any of that
but the general consensus is is that
this is something that Tammy has noticed
and she's trying to figure out how it's
possible that someone that their prints
would be reversed right so she knows
that the counterfeit agent Cooper but
why does this guy have mirror image
prints of the original mr. strawberry
whenever evil coop brings up the name
mr. strawberry the warden is definitely
put off like he has like an unsettled
look and then he puts his hand up
against his mouth and you know when you
go back and watch it again it's really
obvious that this is happening and that
it's related to what Cooper just said
right evil coop just said so there's
plenty of theories going around about
this one about maybe you know that's
just a code word for something that he's
used for illegal dealings or someone
that he knows and evil coops basically
telling him that name in that context so
to scare the [ __ ] out of them basically
the band that played at the end their
name trouble and another credit thing
was that David Lynch's son is the guitar
player of the band you see his name
right there that's kind of an
interesting thing you know for me when I
was watching I was like man this is this
band I didn't know who they were
obviously but I was like you know
they're definitely a band that was made
to be in a David Lynch movie you know I
was thinking of link wray and some other
stuff and it's it's pretty cool that
it's actually his son that's in the band
then there's this this sonny jim blink
backwards theory and i people who are
behind it really make a good case that
he blinks backwards it's hard to tell
for me i did watch to slow down and
reverse versions and yeah it looks like
when you turned around it looks like a
full word blink but um it didn't it
didn't jump out to me at the time
probably because i was thinking about
the fact that dougie coop had shed a
tear so yeah this is like a rabbit hole
because a lot of people are tying a lot
of things into this and then they're
bringing up the idea that perhaps denise
was walking backwards i'm not going to
go down that rabbit hole right now but
it's something to keep in mind you know
if you see something that looks weird
maybe it's being played in Reverse the
deputy and the drugs someone pointed out
that the guy in the bar who takes the
Morley pack from richard horn was in
fact the deputy that we saw that was
kind of skeptical making fun of the log
lady and it is it's deputy Chet when I
called him Chad his name's actually Chad
it was the way that Frank Tremont said
it so yeah deputy Chad if you put these
two pictures together he's obviously
into some shady stuff with something
that I'm sure is going to come out later
then we have these screams during the
alarm bells we have two different
screens that clearly come up over
security monitors one looks like
somebody working in a machine shop I
don't know exactly what they're doing
and the other is a cooking show where
three people are standing behind a table
and there's a bowl of something red
there and yeah I don't know what that is
either but it is something that's
peculiar I mean he took control the
security system and then these two
particular shots were put in there as
something what that is I don't really
know and the last thing is they when we
looked at the blackberry and we looked
at the woman in the beginning who was
using to communicate you know using it
to reach out to the communication device
or at least that's what we thought was
going down
she writes argent to and I was wondering
because argent is a word that I'm not
that I may have heard the word I don't
know what it means that's hard I think
the name rather than anything in
particular but then I was thinking about
it after the fact and that device was in
Argentina where we last saw Phillip
Jeffries
so she typed Sargent to in and maybe
argent is related to the word Argentina
one last thing I guess I guess maybe the
argent and this will be a half thing
because I'm going to call the video ten
things you might have missed but on the
house where the drugged-out mother lives
we see this symbol on the front and it
kind of to me at first I thought of
crosses but then when I thought about
how its laid out it kind of reminds me
of an old TV erial like you know the
antenna is on top of the house none of
the other houses in the neighborhood
have anything like it from my
understanding I went back and looked at
the different shots and you don't see it
and yeah so what do you guys think it
means I am getting ready to start
working on my Q&A for this episode which
will come out the day after this one
you're watching right now so if you have
any more questions post them in the
comments of the episode five recap and
review or here and then I'll pick out a
bunch of them and see what we can find
out please subscribe go back and check
out my other videos if you haven't seen
them yet um thanks for watching I'll
talk to you soon